chaque nouvelle vie appelle une vie à
perdre l'équilibre du monde doit
être maintenu es-tu prêt à accepter
le risque
je suis prêt à mourir pour champ la
vie grandir en moi pomper un monstre marin
découper son coeur tu vas tomber
enceinte  le mari d'une princesse ne
peut être découvert qu'à un tournoi et
si je ne l'aime pas toi où t'es-
tu caché tout ce temps quel âge
as-tu ouvre cette porte pour que je puisse te
voir me montrer ce que tu as promis que tu es  un
prince tu ne peux pas être l'ami d'un fils
de serviteur
si jamais je te revois avec lui et
nous le regretterons tous les deux nous devons garder
cela secret entre vous et moi je ne peux pas
revenir sur ma parole je suis  rien pour toi
personne n'a le droit de remettre en question ma volonté
je ne connais pas la connexion de Jane Smith oh si
mignon
viens
personne ne t'aimera jamais comme moi je
veux redevenir jeune
tu n'as aucune idée à quel point je te voulais